distribution des prix à oslo le nobel de
la paix à ercé reza à genève la médaille
en scène pour les réfugiés à monsieur
giscard d'estaing nouvelles difficultés
pour l'europe agricole dossier épineux
le mouton et le vin virus vende sa paris
deuxième étape d'une tournée
diplomatique en europe pour les
amériques madame monsieur bonsoir
elle s'appelle soeur thérésa autrement
dit puisqu'à ce jour son nom était
personne c'est pourquoi cet inconnu qui
vient de recevoir le prix nobel de la
paix à oslo cet après midi un prix qui
ne représente pas pour elle la gloire
mais l'argent qu'elle donnera aux
pauvres de calcutta dont elle s'occupe
avec les missionnaires de son ordre à 69
ans on pourrait dire et c'est le plus
bel hommage à lui rend que c'est pour sa
vie que soeur thérésa reçu le nobel de
la paix une vie toute entière consacrée
aux déshérités dont elle s'occupe
vraiment je veux dire en vivant pour eux
et au milieu d'eux denise bauer ce sont
la persévérance la foi et la droiture
qui se voit aujourd'hui récompensé en la
personne de mère teresa elle a 18 ans
lorsqu'elle prend la route de calcutta
où pendant 20 ans elle enseignera la
géographie à de jeunes indiennes de la
bourgeoisie mais très vite mère teresa
est bouleversée par la misère
hallucinante des bidonvilles elle décide
de quitter sa congrégation et dans le
dénuement le plus grand en fond d'une
nouvelle celle des soeurs missionnaires
de la charité
en 1954 elle inaugure le premier mouroir
là les soeurs assisteront ce pouvons
mourir
l'oeuvre se développe très rapidement
aujourd'hui les soeurs missionnaires de
la charité sont présentes dans 5
continents
elle ouvre des écoles recueille les
preuves et les soigne cette petite
religieuse gougaud cela va aujourd'hui
69 ans devenue malgré elle une vedette
de l'actualité elle se réjouit de
l'attribution du prix nobel de la paix
en effet profitant du discours qu'elle
devait prononcer à oslo mère teresa
lancé un vibrant appel aux pays
industrialisés
insistant sur leur devoir de solidarité
envers les pauvres de ce monde
après avoir pris position entre
l'avortement elle demandait que l'on
annuler le banquet offert en général
lauréats et dont le montant s'élève à 6
mille dollars ces six mille dollars a
ajouté 11 191 me du prix nobel lui ont
été remis ils serviront à se courir les
pauvres ils et tradition que le prix
nobel de la paix sera remis à oslo le
même jour que les 10 autres prix nobel
qui eux ont été décernés à stockholm par
le roi gustav de suède
le président de la république française
monsieur giscard d'estaing s'est rendu
lui à genève aujourd'hui pour recevoir
le prix nansen que lui a remis le haut
commissaire des nations unies pour
services exceptionnels rendus à la cause
des réfugiés vous savez que la france se
situe dans le peloton de tête des pays
qui se présentent comme des terres
d'asile privilégié pour tous les
réfugiés à travers moi à lille président
c'est la france qui est honorée et dans
une lettre le chef de l'état à
d'ailleurs rendu hommage à toutes les
associations françaises d aide aux
réfugiés
le prix de 50 mille dollars servira au
financement d'un hôpital de campagne
français pour le cambodge et à la
construction d'une école dans un camp de
réfugiés d'afrique
au botswana la cérémonie d'aujourd'hui
avaient mieux à l'occasion de la journée
des droits de l'homme organisée par les
nations unies et dans son discours le
président français a particulièrement
insisté sur le fait que partout où il ya
des réfugiés il y a mise en cause des
droits de l'homme si fillon leclerc par
tout où il ya des réfugiés
et il y à aussi il y as avant des
violations des droits de l'homme
ceux qui aujourd'hui partent pour l'exil
le font parce qu'un droit élémentaire
leur est refusé pour certains c'est le
droit de rester dans leur pays ou tout
au moins d'y être libre pour d'autres
c'est la possibilité matérielle d'y
vivre
le logement l'emploi la famille la
simple subsistance
tout ce qui semblait assuré devient
soudain précaire la sécurité est menacée
la liberté compromise
et cette précarité même paraît moins
supportable que les incertitudes et les
risques souvent mortelle de l'exode
il faut en effet qu'un homme ou qu'une
femme ait perdu ses droits essentiels
pour qu'il se résigne à l'exil c'est
pourquoi le problème des réfugiés est
inséparable de celui des droits de
l'homme on rappelle desquels
l'organisation des nations unies
consacrent comme chaque année ce jour du
10 descend en ce jour anniversaire
comment ne pas dire notre inquiétude
devant le décalage entre le droit et la
réalité double confusion en iran
politique d'abord l'ancien homme fort du
conseil de la révolution monsieur banny
ça repart en mission à tabriz dans
l'azerbaïdjan toujours en décidant et en
même temps il déclare dans une interview
un journal libanais que son pays n'ayant
pas réussi à faire primer le procès du
chat sur la sphère de la prise d'otages
il ne restait plus qu'à s'avouer vaincu
confusion ensuite sur le terrain à
tabriz
les derniers évènements tournent autour
de la prise et de la reprise des studios
de la télévision par les partisans de
comédie et de l'ayatollah mahdavi
brunoise
ce matin des militaires contrôlaient
l'accès de l'immeuble de la radio et de
la télévision servant en quelque sorte
de force tampon entre les fidèles de
l'imam khomeiny et les insurgés
cette hier soir à la suite de
l'intervention d'une auto mitrailleuses
que les partisans de layette de la
charia tu m'as d'art y avait de nouveau
repris le contrôle des bâtiments
plusieurs personnes auraient trouvé la
mort au cours de l'assaut seul programme
sur les écrans ces derniers jours des
diapositives représentants ce qu'il faut
bien aujourd'hui appelée des deux
adversaires politiques de l'iran
révolutionnaire l'imam khomeiny et
l'ayatollah csars yatma d'arrêt dernier
rebondissement cet après midi après un
appel de l'imam khomeiny pour que les
fauteurs de trouble souhaitent arrêter
sans retard les gardiens de la
révolution
pénétrer dans les locaux par une porte
dérobée les partisans de l'ayatollah
chariatte mari était expulsé et emmenés
vers une destination inconnue
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur banny sabre est
arrivé aujourd'hui à tabriz il est
chargé d'une mission d'information
ces affrontements d ordonner qu'il a pu
chercher à comprendre ne font que
traduire la lutte d'influencé entre les
partisans d'un libéralisme et d'un
pouvoir régional que la nouvelle
constitution ne garantit pas ceux de
l'ayatollah czaja travail face aux
fidèles de l'imam khomeiny ces
affrontements font en tout cas passer au
second plan un d'iran la sphère des
otages de l'ambassade américaine
oui j'ajouterai que dans la sphère de
l'assassinât du neveu du shah d'iran
scotland yard a confirmé cet après midi
qu'un homme qui serait mêlé à
l'assassinât de paris est interrogé à la
fois par des policiers anglais et
français puis j'ajouterai ce soir que le
quai d'orsay a condamné l'attentât
commis à paris et dans son communiqué le
quai d'orsay indique que la france
respectueuse souveraineté des autres ne
tolérera pas que l'on ne respecte pas la
sienne pour essayer de débloquer la
situation les américains continuent de
développer leur offensive diplomatique
le ministre de la justice et à l'est où
il a saisi la cour internationale de
justice dans laquelle les iraniens n'ont
pas pour l'instant l'intention de se
présenter
quant à monsieur cyrus vance le
secrétaire d'état américain aux affaires
étrangères il a commencé aujourd'hui sa
tournée européenne par londres il est
ensuite arrivé cet après midi à paris où
il a rencontré monsieur jean françois
poncet est il digne ce soir avec le
président de la république monsieur
giscard d'estaing à la demande du
président carter je suis venu à paris
pour des consultations sur la situation
en iran nous avons à faire face à une
situation difficile et dangereuse dans
ce pays en dépit de la réprobation
générale exprimée par la communauté
internationale et contrairement au droit
international et diplomates américains
sont toujours retenus en otages
nos amis et nos alliés partagent notre
inquiétude
basée sur les valeurs et les principes
humanitaires du droit international la
france s'est exprimé clairement son sais
pas ce qui m'attend devant le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu que dans une
déclaration de la communauté européenne
le peuple américain est très
reconnaissant pour le soutien que lui
accorde pendant cette crise le
gouvernement et le peuple français
j'ajouterai à ce qui vient d'être dit et
au conditionnel que d'après les
informations qu'a pu recueillir notre
correspondant à londres philippe
harrouard au terme de sa tournée
européenne
et si tout va bien monsieur vente aurait
l'intention de demander à l'europe
l'embargo économique de l'iran il est
vrai que les responsables américains
paraissent avoir le
union public derrière ce qui n'avait pas
été le cas depuis longtemps
dans l'ensemble cette majorité
silencieuse garde son calme à quelques
exceptions près toutefois comme le
montre cet exemple filmé par l'équipe
d'un de nos correspondants aux états
unis claudine
ban
c'était il ya quelques jours dans le
vieux stade olympique de los angeles un
sénateur avait appelé la population à
une manifestation de patriotisme pour
prouver au monde et à l'ayatollah
khomeini que l'amérique était solidaire
unie et prête si on lui demandait à
témoigner de sa force
ébranlé par la prise d'otages la mise à
sac de plusieurs de leurs ambassades
ces californiens là au moins avaient
besoin de se redonner confiance et il
est inquiétant
je n'ai rien pour le chat ni compte
je suis simplement venu ici pour mon
pays
je pense que nous sommes très puissant
aujourd'hui superman est américain
superman est puissant et nous sommes
américains nous montons notre force
des gens comme vous dit l'orateur ou que
l'amérique est un pays fort
à
on va
non
ils vont
oh
on montre aux iraniens qu'ici aussi on
savait brûlé des effigies et témoigner
des même déchaînement que la foule de
téhéran présenter chaque jour sur le
petit écran
à
la manifestation fête était un spectacle
pour télévision de mauvais goût sans
doute et qui n'aura attiré que 6000
personnes mais qui a permis de faire
savoir haut ce que beaucoup d'américains
pensent bas libérer les otages
sinon les réactions de l'amérique
profonde comme il est convenu de dire ce
sera d'ailleurs le thème de notre
journal de 20h de demain soir qui aura
lieu depuis un petit village du centre
des états unis d'où l'on pourra mieux
comprendre comment les américains
perçoivent la situation actuelle sur le
terrain et non pas seulement comme on a
l'habitude de le voir à travers les
milieux diplomatiques et politiques de
washington puis je en suis aux annonces
ce soir tout de suite après le journal
question de temps consacré au pétrole
jean pierre elkabbach et oui berio
présente une émission spéciale conçu et
préparé par simon dre avec d'abord un
journal fiction comme si vous y étiez
dont le titre pourrait être si un jour
l'or noir ça va être cool et suivi d'un
reportage bernard ap de christian giroux
autopsie d'une grande compagnie
pétrolière elf aquitaine
une émission qui sera suivi demain soir
d'un dossier de l'écran spécial pétrole
avec sur le même plateau
james schlesinger ancien ministre du
président carter le ministre koweïtien
du pétrole
le secrétaire général adjoint de l'opep
le ministre français de l'industrie
monsieur giraud et encore d'autres
invités que vous découvrirez demain soir
en france c'est demain que les députés
vont s'attaquer à la loi d'orientation à
l'école proposé et présenté par le
gouvernement
les deux dernières lois date est de 60
et 62 elle avait pour but de moderniser
l'agriculture traditionnelle
on en est aujourd'hui au deuxième stade
transformer l'agriculture en véritable
industrie diriger vers l'exportation
jean louis calmettes faire franchir à
l'agriculture et à l'industrie
agroalimentaire une nouvelle étape de
développement
tel est l'objectif de la loi
d'orientation
quatre volets la composent un volet
économique avec notamment la création
d'un conseil d'orientation de l'économie
agricole et alimentaire
un volet foncier surtout pour accroître
le nombre de jeunes agriculteurs qui
s'installent un volet social agricole
pour principalement revaloriser les
retraites des agriculteurs
enfin un volet aménagement rural avec
notamment la création d' opération
appelée remembrement aménagements pour
éviter les excès parfois provoqués par
le remembrement classique mais voyons
chaque volet un par un
l'orientation des productions agricoles
non seulement en quantité mais aussi en
qualité est le fer de lance du volet
économique
on parlera désormais de politique
alimentaire cette politique concernera
les producteurs bien sûr mais aussi les
industries de transformation et les
consommateurs dans ce même sens une
industrie agroalimentaire puissante et
compétitive est un objectif majeur de la
loi d'orientation surtout pour
développer nos exportations sur le volet
foncier
si la loi fait en sorte de favoriser
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
elle tend également à favoriser le
fermage et à éviter une augmentation
trop rapide du prix des terres agricoles
de plus les successions seront réglés
sans faire peser sur l'héritier qui
devient agriculteur une charge
financière trop lourde
quant au volet social de la loi s'ils
améliorent les retraites des
agriculteurs
il se penche aussi sur le statut des
conjoints en leur assurant la qualité
d'exploitant à l'un et à l'autre la vie
de tous les jours devraient en être
amélioré enfin le volet aménagement
rural prévoit un inventaire des terres
agricoles dans chaque département ainsi
quand des travaux d'urbanisme amputeront
des terres agricoles inscrits à
l'inventaire
ils ne pourront être entrepris qu'après
avis d'une commission spécialisée
c'est le principal point du volet avec
rappelons le le remembrement
aménagements voilà les grandes lignes de
cette loi cadre qui va donc subir
l'assaut des joutes parlementaires
qu'elle ne manquera pas de susciter
oui la discussion cette loi ne sera pas
très facile comme le laisse entendre
jean louis calmes et jeanne en compte
déjà 600 amendements déposés
monsieur méhaignerie vous êtes notre
ministre de l'agriculture vous êtes en
direct de bruxelles vous participez au
conseil des ministres
neuf est ce que ça ne vous fait pas peur
c'est 600 amendements dont on parle
non cela fait beaucoup d'heures puisque
probablement la loi ne sera pas terminée
samedi prochain c'est à dire quatre
jours de débats mais je crois que ces
quatre jours vitaux pour l'avenir de
l'agriculture et les 15 prochaines
années
on avait même parlé d'une session
extraordinaire pour arriver au bout de
cette discussion est ce qu il en est
toujours question monsieur le ministre
pour le moment voyons d'abord à
l'assemblée nationale à quelle date nous
terminerons cette première partie du
débat puisque ensuite le débat doit
s'engager au sénat mais là aussi après
une période de réflexion des sénateurs
bien l'une des critiques les plus
virulents vient des jeunes agriculteurs
qui estime que votre loi d'orientation
ne va pas réduire l'exode rural autant
qu'il le faudrait
l'exode rural doit être limité doit être
réduit nous le pouvons et nous le devons
pour que l'agriculture participe à la
solution des problèmes de l'emploi
comment on assure un meilleur niveau
technologique en développant nos
débouchés en recherchant de nouveaux
produits et en facilitant et en
renforçant l'organisation économique
c'est la voie que nous ont montré les
grands pays dans le monde et je rappelle
juste que nous sommes au terme de quinze
ans que nous avons remporté de nombreux
succès et que nous sommes devenus le
deuxième ou troisième pays exportateur
du monde bien l'armée sioniste volant à
bruxelles puisque vous y êtes
aujourd'hui ça ne fait pas très bien à
passer d'après des dépêches la grande
bretagne l'italie aurait demandé cet
après midi lors de la réunion une
dévaluation de 5% de la livre et de la
lyre verte la monnaie européenne
agricole et où seriez toujours selon les
dépêches montré très réservé sur ces
deux demandes
nous estimons qu'on ne peut pas résoudre
un problème individuel sont solutionner
les problèmes en instance depuis des
mois je pense au dossier du vin au
dossier du mouton et je souhaite
nous demandons que chaque pays fassent
un effort si nous voulons que la
communauté avance mais est-ce que si on
accorde cette dévaluation on en parle
pour demain est ce que ça veut dire
qu'on est prêts accordés aux anglais un
petit peu tout ce qu'ils demandent et
que par exemple il n'y aura pas de de
réglementation sur la viande de mouton à
laquelle les anglais sont hostiles en
sait c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui nous estimons que nous ne
sommes pas en main
ur d'apporter une solution positive à la
demande individualisé de la grande
bretagne que nous sommes prêts à
progresser dans la voie communautaire à
condition que le dossier du mouton
puisse être solutionnée c'est à dire
pour nous que nous offrions aux
producteurs une garantie de revenus pour
l'avenir car beaucoup n'ont pas d'autre
choix que la production vie c'est la
même chose sur le dossier du vin ou là
nous avons à la fois besoin de sécurité
et d'une adaptation de l'offre à la
demande
c'est la raison pour laquelle la france
sur ce point et ferme
elle n'est pas la seule nous estimons
que la grande bretagne comme tous les
pays doivent prendre des positions
communautaires
vous allez me dire si j'ai bien
interpréter ou mal interprétées comme on
lit souvent des journalistes monsieur le
ministre est ce qu'on pourrait
éventuellement penser à un marchandage
c'est à dire que vous souhaiteriez sur
la dévaluation de la livre anglaise un
livre verte anglaise et booth et vous ne
seriez pas sur la réglementation en ce
qui concerne les exportations de moutons
donnant donnant ce que nous voulons
c'est réglé les problèmes d'ensemble de
la communauté avec les autres pays nous
y sommes parvenus en juin en mai sur les
montants compensatoires monétaire et les
prix nous mettrons le temps qu'il faudra
pour solutionner les problèmes en
instance aujourd'hui chacun défend ses
intérêts nationaux
mais l'intérêt communautaire peut te
petr parfaitement conciliables avec
l'intérêt national c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour le moment nous ne sommes
pas prêts à apporter une solution
concrète à un problème si l'on ignore
les autres et si l'on ignore nos
réalités et nos problèmes fondamentaux
dernière question monsieur le ministre
on a l'impression en ce moment que le
sentiment profond des agriculteurs
français c'est un petit peu comme aurait
dit jeanne d'arc bouter les anglais hors
de la communauté européenne
je constate qu'actuellement l'ensemble
des opinions publiques et chauffée à
blanc je ne crois pas que cela soit sain
pour la communauté
j'ai toujours dit qu'il ne fallait pas
prendre à témoin en permanence les
radios les télévisions car sinon nous
allions blocage de la politique agricole
commune
il n'en reste pas moins que les
principes de la politique agricole
commune auxquels les huit autres états
sont fermement attachés parce qu'il n'ya
d'autres solutions que la prod la
politique agricole commune
la grande bretagne doit faire des pas en
avant et c'est à ces conditions que nous
pourrons régler les problèmes je
reconnais et c'est ce que les
agriculteurs français l'opinion publique
quelquefois ne comprend pas il faut
savoir et nous l'avons dit aujourd'hui
qu'il n'ya pas d'autre alternative
possible à la politique agricole commune
mais que nous devons faire face
courageusement aux problèmes financiers
que l'efficacité de cette politique a
conduit je pense à l'efficacité des
politiques les pierres qui fait
qu'actuellement nous avons du mal à voir
la consommation suivre l'augmentation de
production
merci monsieur le ministre le comité
directeur du parti socialiste qui s'est
tenu à paris ce week-end n'a pas atténué
les divergences entre la majorité et la
minorité du parti autrement dit entre
monsieur mitterrand d'un côté et
monsieur rocard et me roy de l'autre et
aujourd'hui comme pour jeter de l'huile
sur le feu deux élus socialistes
monsieur d'arras du pas-de-calais
monsieur baumet du gard deux fédérations
très importante du ps écrivent tout
simplement si je puis dire dans le
journal le monde
monsieur mitterrand a encore un rôle
considérable à jouer mais chacun sait
bien qu'en sport collectif ce n'est pas
toujours celui qui a réussi la percée
qui peut marquer le but autrement dit
noël copains sans changer de vocabulaire
ça veut dire qu'il propose tout
simplement monsieur mitterrand de
rejoindre le banc de touche non si j'ai
bien compris
oui et c'est disons qu'à monsieur
mitterrand reste quand même pour
l'instant l'arbitré je crois que tout le
problème du parti socialiste tient au
fait qu'il a deux candidats possibles
aux élections présidentielles et que la
transfo mitterrand est le mieux placé à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste tandis
que l'autre michel rocard à mieux placés
dans l'opinion si l'on en croit des
sondages qui sont de plus en plus
fréquent mais pour être candidat à la
présidence il faut d'abord être le
candidat du parti alors michel rocard
avait rappelé à metz en particulier au
concret du mois d'avril qu'il ne serait
pas candidat à la candidature si
françois mitterrand l'été lui-même ce
qui veut dire que michel rocard ne peut
être candidat que si françois mitterrand
renonce de lui-même à l'être et passe
pour ainsi dire le relais à michel
rocard c'est je crois le voeu que
faisait secrètement des amis de michel
rocard jusqu'aujourd'hui
et c'est le voeu qu'exprime maintenant
très clairement messieurs gomez et des
races il le dit
sans trop de ménagement ils le disent
avec des fleurs mais avec le croit des
fleurs qui ressemble peut-être un peu
trop bas des chrysanthèmes pour être
bien accueillis ne distille pas que la
place de françois mitterrand est déjà
inscrite dans l'histoire alors la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui est de
savoir si le mouvement favorable à
michel rocard dans l'opinion publique va
maintenant se transposer à l'intérieur
du parti socialiste c'est je crois ce
qu'il ya derrière le point de vue de
messieurs gaumais et d'arras ex
premièrement bien alors il est tombé une
dépêche juste avant ce journal noël
j'aurais eu une explication sur des
patients bien on nous donne l'analyse
qu'a tenus dire monsieur chirac devant
le comité central et qui étaient restés
inconnus jusqu'à présent puisque le
comité central s'est déroulé à huis clos
alors de phrase de monsieur chirac est
le président du rpr dénonce chez ceux
qui ont mission de guider le pays
je cite l'incapacité quasi générale de
répondre aux questions pressantes des
français et monsieur chirac qui ajoute
un peu plus loin il ya deux catégories
d'hommes d'état ceux qui sont convaincus
que la volonté peut et doit changer
quelque chose et ceux qui s'en remettent
à la volonté des autres c'est bien je
crois la confirmation s'il en était
besoin que toutes les stratégies du rpr
s'inscrit désormais elles aussi dans une
perspective présidentielle
merci donne politique encore au sénat
cette fois ci monsieur raymond barre a
déclaré aujourd'hui qu'il n'y aurait pas
de vote bloqué sur le budget comme
ç'avait été le cas vous en souvenez à
l'assemblée nationale et que d'autre
part il avait décidé d'accepter l'octroi
d'une demi part fiscale supplémentaire
pour le cinquième enfant
après 10 mois d'absence monsieur henri
fiszbin a fait sa réapparition
aujourd'hui au conseil municipal de
paris depuis le début de l'année
monsieur fiszbin a successivement
démissionné de son poste
secrétaire de la fédération de paris du
parti communiste du comité central du
parti communiste et enfin de la
présidence de son groupe au conseil de
paris
on a dit tout ces dernières semaines que
monsieur fils d'un était en désaccord
avec la direction du parti communiste
lui n'a pas fait de déclarations semaine
d2 mercredi pour les collégiens et
lycéens cette semaine justement en effet
demain si les établissements du
secondaire et seront ouverts il n'y aura
probablement que peu de cours assurées
cinq syndicats d'enseignants appellent à
cesser le travail pour 24 heures
le snes syndicat national d'éducation
physique de l'enseignement technique cgt
des enseignants de la cfdt et le
syndicat national des collèges unis n'a
limité qui ne s'était pas vu depuis très
longtemps une grève qui a pour but
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et d'emploi des enseignants ainsi que le
réemploi de tous les maîtres auxiliaires
à noter que le syndicat national des
instituteurs et la direction de la fen
ont refusé de participer à la grève en
affirmant je les cite qu'il s'agit là
d'un fourre tout sans efficacité
fin de citation la fédération cornec des
parents d'élèves elle soutient cette
journée de grève
les aiguilleurs du ciel vont ils
reprendre leur grêle c'est une des
hypothèses envisagées car les entretiens
d'aujourd'hui avec le ministre des
transports ont été tendus les pouvoirs
publics refusant par exemple de revenir
sur les sanctions et les syndicats
trouvant insuffisantes les propositions
portant sur les rémunérations des
assemblées générales ont lieu en ce
moment même dans les différents centres
de france et une dépêche indique ce soir
que le personnel d'athis mons c'est à
dire celui de la tour de contrôle d'orly
est favorable à une reprise du mouvement
sous une forme qui n'a pas encore été
défini pour vous donner un avant goût de
la soirée pétrole sur antenne 2 au
moment où le journal économique anglais
financiel times annonce une hausse
possible de 30% du pétrole au prochain
sommet de l'opep vous propose d'aller
faire un tour sur la côte ouest des
états unis où ils se mobilisent sont en
train de se débarrasser de leurs belles
américaines pour acheter des petites
européenne une enquête de claude guéant
c'est une des agglomérations les plus
étendus du monde 150 km de bungalows du
sinn de parking et avenues rectilignes
c'est la ville du monde qui possède le
plus dense réseau d'autoroutes où il ya
le plus grand nombre de voitures par
habitant et où chaque habitant parcours
le plus grand nombre de kilomètres c'est
los angeles
la ville construite pour la voiture
alors il ya six mois pendant la
révolution
quand le pétrole d'iran ne coulait plus
en a volé des camions-citernes dégainer
le colt pour être servi et parfois on a
tiré la prise aujourd'hui est passé mais
voici la seconde il y aura la troisième
la crise est permanente
alors les premiers et les seuls les
californiens ont adopté le système du
pair et impair
on prend de l'essence un jour sur deux
selon le numéro d'immatriculation de la
voiture les faits remarquables
les californiens ne veulent plus que des
petites voitures qui consomment peu les
ventes des plus gros modèles de voitures
américaines ont chuté de 40 % en un an
cent dix mille ouvriers de l'industrie
automobile ont été mises au chômage et
sur le marché de l'occasion on attend en
vain le client des modèles récents sont
bradés moins de dix mille francs dans le
même temps certains constructeurs
européens ou japonais en doublé leurs
ventes et la demande est telle qu'il y a
même plus de prix
oui c'est que les usines y met une crise
affiche une étiquette sur la fenêtre et
on y cela comme un pas avec la loi et ça
dure hier en la droite chargé en plus ou
en a le droit de changer en moins ça
dépend
quelque chose la saison si on a besoin
de plus de ventes ou si c'est un modèle
qui est recherché on n'a pas beaucoup on
va changer plus alors par exemple en ce
moment est ce que vous vendez plus cher
une voiture une petite voiture que vous
demeuriez vendu il ya quelques temps est
ce que votre bénéfice est aujourd'hui
plus grands ah oui peuvent beaucoup
sépare de mon esprit c'est tout et on
les vend en achetant une voiture
européenne dans quelques années tous
veulent à revendre beaucoup plus que
vous avez acheté et avec une voiture
américaine vous avez peur de roulement
dessus en fait ce qu'attendent les
californiens c'est ça le progrès on fait
déjà des choses étonnantes comme cette
voiture sans chauffeur
tous les laboratoires travaillent sur
l'énergie solaire et la voiture
électrique on est sûr que la première a
roulé sera californienne parce qu'il ya
du profit
on accepte en attendant les limitations
de la distribution de l'essence et la
hausse de son prix bon gré mal gré
on a essayé d'imposer un peu comme on
l'a fait à paris et dans d'autres villes
en france
certaines mesures est d'abord le quart
poule
c'est à dire l'encouragement à
s'organiser pour utiliser à plusieurs
qu'une seule voiture est par exemple
partir au bureau et revenir ensemble et
puis pour inciter les california air a
effectivement voyager à plusieurs on a
créé les lignes diamant c'est à dire des
voies réservées aux autobus et aux
voitures qui transporte au moins deux
personnes mais en californie comme en
france on a des idées et en effet les
voitures transportent plusieurs
personnes
des mannequins ou des poupées gonflables
et l'expérience vient d'être arrêté où
il est toujours en prévision de ses
mauvais jours vingt pays occidentaux
membres de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie dont ne fait pas partie la
france ont décidé aujourd'hui à paris de
limiter leurs importations de pétrole
en 1981 il faut en 1981 pendant encore
deux informations philip morris d'abord
l'un des deux mineurs trier des gardiens
de la paix a battu à paris la semaine
dernière a été inculpé aujourd'hui
d'homicide volontaire et enfin une
information en pratique
à la veille des élections des
prud'hommes de nombreux électeurs
d'électeurs s'étonne d'avoir reçu
plusieurs cas deux trois quatre voies
ça s'explique car certaines personnes
peuvent être à la fois salarié dans
plusieurs entreprises ou bien à la fois
salarié ou employeurs ça dit il ne doit
voter qu'une fois sous peine de
sanctions
la météo donc pour terminer le temps est
tellement mauvais que nous avons
convoqué d'urgence laurent broomhead
pour nous rassurer laurent il fait
mauvais partout comme sur ces images et
donc nous allons voir et qui nous
viennent de bretagne
oui nous avions perdu l'habitude de voir
ces images de tempête pour comportant la
tempête et de saison sur les côtes de
l'atlantique de la manche et de la mer
du nord est ici en bretagne on a observé
des pointes de vent de 115 kilomètres à
l'heure ce vent va continuer cette nuit
avec l'arrivée d'une nouvelle zone de
pluie qui traversera le pays d'ouest en
est ce la partie nord
cette nuit et demain matin après son
passage qu'il ya dans la journée surtout
venant du pays le temps sera variable
avec une alternance de passages le jus
de très courtes éclaircies de nombreuses
averses sous les rafales de vent
toujours prêt fort en ange sur la moitié
sud au contraire le ciel deviendra de
plus en plus nuageux à couvert dans la
journée avec bip